How long should I wait to put the bulb under the covers? I started this past Sunday night and you
suggested I start with it under the bed. Well, um, because you said you were prone to having
work side of a reaction. So you don't, you're trying to, I'm trying to just start slowly. If you're like,
no, I'm having no trouble, whatever. Well, then put it up in bed, but leave it a little bit farther
away from you. And then slowly moving closer to you. So you can play with it. You can play with it.
You can play with it. You can start with it embedded. If you wake up in the middle of the night,
you just kind of feel like it's kind of knocking your socks off then slip it under the bed. So, um,
just play with it. I just want you to be safe. It's own. Um, and this person who's asking the question
has an atelier Robin. Remember, you have to be a little more careful with that because versus the
true right, because it puts out three times the energy. So with people with the true right,
they're wondering why I'm answering this question this way. Um, and I am always told people with
the true right, just to put it in your bed, struggle with it, you're going to be fine. And 99.9% of the time
that's true, but unless you have blind, then you'd ever do that. But, um, if you have the atelier
Robin, you might sometimes want to go a little slow.